let's say that I have the vector
actually going to give it the vector a
and let's say that it is equal to two
one so we could draw it right over here
so it's equal to 2/1 so in the
horizontal if we were to start at the
origin in the Hort we would move to in
the horizontal direction and one in the
vertical direction so we would end up
right over here now what I want to do is
think about how we can define
multiplying this vector by a scalar so
for example if I were to say if I were
to say three times three times the
vector a which is the same thing as
saying three times to one so three is
just a number one way to think about a
scalar quantity it is just a number
versus a vector Y or this is giving you
it's giving you how much you're moving
in the various directions right over
here it's giving you both a magnitude
magnitude and a direction while this is
just a plain number right over here but
how would we how would we define
multiplying three times this vector
right over here
well one reasonable thing that might
jump out at you is well why don't we
just multiply the three times each of
these components so this could be equal
to so we have two and one and we're
going to multiply each of these times
three so three times two and three times
one and then the resulting vector is
still going to be a two dimensional
vector and it's going to be the two
dimensional vector six three now
encourage you to get some graph paper
out in to actually plot this vector and
think about how it relates to this
vector right over this vector right over
here so let me do that so the vector six
three if we started at the origin we
would move six in the horizontal
direction one two three four five six
and three of the vertical one two three
so it gets us right over there so it
would look it would look like this so
what just happened to this vector well
notice what one way to think about is
what's changed and what has not changed
about this
enter well what's not changed is still
pointing in the same direction so this
right over here has the same same
direction multiplying by the scalar at
least the way we defined it did not
change the direction that my vector is
going in or at least in this case it
didn't but it did change its magnitude
its magnitude is now three times longer
which makes sense because we multiplied
it by three one way to think about it is
we scaled it up by three the scalar
scaled up the vector that might make
sense or might give an intuition of
where that word scalar came from the
scalars can when you multiply it it
scales up it scales up with AK vector it
increased its magnitude by three without
changing its direction but let's do
something interesting let's multiply our
vector a let's now multiply it by a
negative number let's actually just
multiply it by negative one just for
simplicity so let's just multiply
negative one negative one times a well
using the convention that we just came
up with we would multiply each of the
components by negative one so 2 times
negative 1 is negative 2 and 1 times
negative 1 is negative 1 so now negative
1 times a is going to be negative 2
negative 1 so if we start at the origin
we would move negative we would move in
the horizontal direction negative 2 and
in the vertical direction negative 1 so
now what happened to the vector now what
happened to the vector when I did that
well now it flipped its direction
multiplying it by this negative 1 it
flipped its direction its magnitude it
actually has not changed but its
direction is now in the exact opposite
direction which makes sense that
multiplying by a negative number would
do that in fact when we just dealt with
the traditional number line that's what
happened if you took 5 times negative 1
well now you're going in the other
direction you're at negative 5 your five
to the left of zero so it makes sense
that this would flip its direction so
you could imagine if you were to take
something like negative 2 times your
vector a negative 2 times your vector
encourage you to pause this video and
try this on your own
what would this give and what would be
the resulting visualization of the
vector well let's see this would be
equal to negative 2 times 2 is negative
4 negative 2 times 1 is negative 2 so
this vector if you were to start at the
origin remember you don't have to start
at the origin but if you were it would
be so you'd go 0 1 2 3 4 1 2 it looks
just like this it looks just like this
and so just to remind ourselves our
original vector a our original vector a
look like this our original vector a
look like this two one looks like this
and then when you multiply it by
negative two you get a vector that looks
like this you get a vector that looks
like this let me draw it like this and
I'm and purposely not having them all
start at the origin because they don't
have to all start at the origin but you
get a vector that looks like this that
looks like this so what's the difference
between a and negative 2 times a well
the negative flipped it over and then
the two flipped it over and now it has
twice the magnitude but because of the
negative it has twice the magnitude in
the other direction